bro he had this instagram [ __ ] broke  down to a science  like to a science you'll think he was  just no i'm doing this no he knew that  like if i did this with that  then this would happen  yeah he got himself signed off on  instagram you know what i mean like he  knew how to get the people to watch  videos like we didn't literally sit down  and spend like an hour to just creating  a scenario just so that he can make a  [ __ ] 30 second video to post that'll  go viral  you know that's how he went from  a couple of hundred thousand followers  to like 17 million  mm-hmm it happened fast you know what i  mean the pump should happen  every antique or something that he would  do it will blow him up he'll get more  followers he'll get more fans he'll get  more engagements he'll get more money  everybody can't relate instagram into  money he's actually transferring them  likes views engagements into actual hard  cash